hallo meine lieben heute gibt es kein
rezept und zwar gibt es heute ein
kleines update zur leider an so weit ist
vielleicht mitbekommen hatte ich habe
vor einigen wochen einen spendenaufruf
gemacht für die leider die leukämie hat
und eben für eine therapie eine gewisse
summe gebraucht hat und wir haben vor
ein paar wochen auch die spendensumme
erreicht und die leider ist es kalt in
amerika und hat die therapie gemacht und
jetzt werde ich eben mal wieder also von
all meinen zuschauern unter den videos
gefragt wie es ihr geht auf instagram
auf facebook auf den messen auf den
messen also überall begleitet mich
eigentlich immer das thema mit leider
was ich auch sehr schön finde weil weil
ich daneben sehe dass meine zuschauer
sich natürlich auch für sie
interessieren
und wir selber wie privat verfolgen das
natürlich auch wer aber auch kontakt zur
familie und auch zoe leider wenn sie
jetzt ja also die zeit wo es ihr nicht
so schlecht ging haben wir auch mit ihr
geschrieben und hat uns immer
geantwortet sprachnachrichten geschickt
und ja jetzt gerade das thema irgendwie
so aktuell weil es immer mehr fragen
kommen und deswegen dachte ich mache
jetzt doch noch kurzen update ich habe
zwar immer auf ihrer facebook seite
verwiesen wo der papa und die familie
immer ein update gibt aber es bekommt
natürlich auch nicht immer jeder mit ja
aktuelle stand also die leider hat diese
katies als therapie gemacht
und leider ist hier hat die aber nicht
angeschlagen sie aus vier mal probiert
der firma probiert und ich meine jetzt
nicht so eine thematik mit drin aber es
muss einfach furchtbar sein weil es auch
jedes mal schmerzen sind und es für sie
im 110 jahre alt schon es nimmt sie halt
sehr mit und jetzt eben als eltern dann
zu hören dass die therapie nicht
anschlägt ich glaube ich wie so ein
schlag ins gesicht weil einfach die
ganze hoffnung immer in dieser therapie
war
und ja jetzt schaltet der aktuelle stand
also der papa hat uns geschrieben und
hat es auch schon auf facebook
veröffentlicht dass diese therapie bei
ihr leider nicht angeschlagen hat und
damit mit den professoren gesprochen und
sie haben auch im schreiben vom vom
krankenhaus genau das ist jetzt noch
eine möglichkeit mit einer nabelschnur
transplantation gebe
was natürlich auch wieder mit kosten
verbunden ist und ja ich finde es da
schwierig ganz viele meiner zuschauer
haben mich jetzt auch schon angesprochen
und viele haben jetzt auch schon
geschrieben weil ja weil sie eben
möchten dass ich wieder helfen natürlich
tun wir das auch also eben braucht jetzt
nicht meinen nur weil jetzt etwas nicht
öffentlich machen das wird dann uns
nicht dafür interessieren oder nicht
helfen oder nicht aktiv sind
es ist schon so wissen aktiv dabei und
wir haben ja auch kontakt zur familie
und wir haben jetzt auch dieses mal
wieder geholfen weil es einfach ja
alleine geht es eben auch nicht und ich
hatte jetzt nur immer das problem also
viele haben mich nach dem ersten video
auch angeschrieben viele andere
betroffene auch eltern mit kranken
kindern oder anderen schicksal haben
auch war schon täglich eigentlich
täglich anrufe haben sich eltern gewesen
ähnliches schicksal immer noch leicht
nicht mit leukämie aber auch andere
schicksale und jedes mal muss ich dann
sagen was wir auch damals im video
gesagt haben wir können nicht allen
helfen wir können nicht jeden zu stein
retten aber für den einen see stand den
wir dem wir helfen bedeutet natürlich
alles und für uns auch richtig stressig
für mich auch sehr schwer vor allem weil
ich halt so ein typ bin ich kann so was
nicht einfach ignorieren oder also mit
geht es auch emotional immer sehr nah
und ich bin auch wirklich als ich bin
sehr dankbar auch dass ich gesund bin
dass wir gesund sind und ich bin
wirklich jeden tag dankbar und mir fällt
es dann auch schwer solchen eltern zu
antworten und zu sagen ich kann nicht
jeden ich kann nicht immer ein
spendenaufruf machen ich kann auch nicht
immer irgendwie etwas posten damit
publik gemacht wird weil ich einfach
eine back & koch seite bin und ich
möchte so was auch immer von meiner
seite fernhalten weil ich einfach möchte
wenn ihr bei mir einschaltet dass ihr
einfach mal abschalten können vom alltag
und mal alles andere vergessen können
einfach nur kochen und backen könnt und
die schönen dinge des lebens sehen könnt
und ja eigentlich möchte ich auch jetzt
wirklich heute so das letzte video dazu
machen jetzt nicht dazu wie gesagt ist
mir nicht egal und es nämlich auch
emotional immer sein mit aber ich möchte
es einfach von meiner seite bisschen
fernhalten möchte ich aber auch sagen
also ihr könnt auf der seite von der
leiter auf der facebook seite natürlich
immer nach
da schreibt der papa immer alle 23 tag
auch was ihn und auch mal jeden tag also
je nach dem wie er eben auch die zeit
findet weil er muss sich um seine kinder
kümmern nicht nur um die leiter sondern
auch um die arena die das natürlich auch
alles mitmachen muss als gesundes kind
der familie sage ich jetzt mal nimmt sie
das ja auch alles mit uns und wir sehen
auch die kommentare und wir sehen keine
kommentare und bei facebook ist es so
als ihr könnt auch wenn ihr kein
facebook account habt werden nicht bei
facebook registriert seid könnt ihr auch
die seite von ihr leider jedes gehen und
trotzdem immer alles sehen was gepostet
wird also alles was der papa ein
schreibt ihr seid dann immer auf dem
aktuellsten stand und deswegen könnt ihr
auch jetzt wieder dahin schauen und
einfach bei schauen und sie dann eben
was gerade aktuell los ist und wie
gesagt und jetzt jetzt kurzum die leider
die therapie wie gesagt hat ich
angeschlagen
sie haben jetzt noch eine zweite
möglichkeit bekommen wir haben auch das
schreiben vom arzt gesehen der fahrer
gepustet ja facebook sieht man das auch
an genau und der vater bietet ein mann
um hilfe
die so verstehen es schnell vorbei kind
und niemand gibt euch eine letzte
möglichkeit dass das wäre noch möglich
ich meine viele schreiben natürlich auch
das kind hat so viel mitgemacht was ja
auch stimmt die letzten vier jahre
kämpfte eigentlich um ihr leben und
kämpft ums überleben und viele schreiben
natürlich auch lass doch endlich los
lasst das kind gehen aber jetzt stellt
euch mal vor ihr seid das selber oder
ihr seid die leiter und ich meinen jeder
hatten lebenswille und sie möchte weiter
leben und versucht natürlich alles dass
sie den kampf besiegt und die eltern von
ihr halt natürlich an jedem strohhalm
fest an jedem stück hoffnung und wir
werden das genauso und ich würde auch
alles dafür tun um ein kind zu retten
und schulkinder soll auch so sein eure
freundin eure schwester und er ist
wichtigste ist halt klar gibt es auch
leute die fragen stellen das ist ganz
klar
diese fragen können wie ich genaue
antwort ich bekomme auch mehr ganz viele
fragen stellen was soll deshalb wird
dafür eine neue therapie sein oder aber
ich hab ja dass ich kann da gar keine
auskunft geben weil ich nicht in der
thematik bin deswegen bitte ich euch
darum geht einfach auf die seite die
eltern beantworten ob das nicht alles
aber so viel wie möglich man alles
können seine beantworten ist kommen wir
viele viele
auch viele aufbauende kommentare was ich
sehr schön finde
also wie gesagt schaut einfach bei ihrer
seite vorbei ich werde die facebook
seite unten in der infobox auch
verlinken
und falls sie irgendwo bei mir
kommentare entdeckt die ich vielleicht
gerade nicht beantworten kann wo es eben
um die leider geht vielleicht seid ihr
so lieb und verweist einfach auf die
facebook seite dass er super ja dann
lange fürs einschalten und ich hoffe ich
konnte euch ein paar fragen beantworten
oder er ein und guckt man bei der
familie vorbei und glaubt mir wir haben
das vertrauen und wir wollen den mädchen
das letzte mal diese hoffnung nicht
nehmen und und ich hoffe dass wir das
hinkriegen weil wir leider die möchte er
sagt ich möchte weiter leben ich möchte
weiter da sein und schaut er vorbei
tschüss